[Music]
I have a friend in Portugal whose
grandfather built a vehicle out of a
bicycle in a washing machine secret
transport his family he did it because
he couldn't afford a car but also
because he knew how to build one there
was a time when we understood how things
work and how they were made so we could
build and repair them or at the very
least making firm decisions about what
to buy
many of these do-it-yourself practices
were lost in the second half of the 20th
century but now the maker community in
the open-source model are bringing this
kind of knowledge about how things work
and what they're made of back into our
lives and I believe we need to take them
to the next level to the component
things are made of for the most part we
still know what traditional materials
like paper and textiles are made of in
how they are produced but now we have
these amazing futuristic composites
plastics that change shape paints that
conduct electricity pigments that change
color fabrics that light up let me show
you some examples so conductive ink
allows us to paint circuits instead of
using the traditional printed circuit
boards or wires in the case of this
little example I'm holding we use it to
create a touch sensor that reacts to my
skin by turning on this little light
conductive ink has been used by artists
but recent developments indicate that
we'll soon be able to use it in laser
printers and pans and this is a sheet of
acrylic infused with colorless light
diffusing particles what this means is
that while regular acrylic only diffuses
light around the edges
this one illuminates across the entire
surface when I turn on the lights around
it two of the known applications for
this material include interior design
and multi-touch systems and
thermochromic pigments change color
the given temperature so I'm going to
place this on a hot plate that is set to
a temperature only slightly higher than
ambient and you can see what happens so
one of the principal applications for
this material is amongst other things in
baby bottles so it indicates when the
contents are cool enough to drink so
these are just a few of what are
commonly known as smart materials in a
few years there will be many of the
objects and technologies we use on a
daily basis we may not yet have the
flying car science fiction promised us
but we can have walls that change color
depending on temperature keyboards that
roll up in windows that become opaque at
the flick of a switch so I'm a social
scientist by training so why am I here
today talking about smart materials well
first of all because I'm a maker I'm
curious about how things work and how
they are made but also because I believe
we should have a deeper understanding of
the components that make up our world
and right now we don't know enough about
this high-tech composites our future
will be made of smart materials are hard
to obtain in small quantities there's
barely any information available on how
to use them in very little isettas but
yet how they are produced so for now
they exist mostly in this realm of trade
secrets and patents only universities
and corporations have access to so
little over three years ago
Kirsty Bali and I started a project we
called open materials it's a website
where we and anyone else who wants to
join us share experiments publish
information encourage others to
contribute whenever they can and
aggregate resources such as research
papers and tutorials by other makers
like ourselves we would like it to
become a large collectively generated
database of do-it-yourself information
on smart materials
but why should we care how smart
materials work and what they are made of
first of all because we can't shape what
we don't understand and what we don't
understand the news ends up shaping us
the objects we use the clothes we wear
the house is reliving all have a
profound impact on our behavior health
and quality of life so if we are to live
in a world made of smart materials we
should know and understand them secondly
and just as important innovation has
always been fueled by tinkerers so many
times amateurs not experts have been
inventors and improvers of things
ranging from mountain bikes to
semiconductors personal computers
airplanes the biggest challenge is that
material science is complex and requires
expensive equipment but that's not
always the case two scientists at
University of Illinois under students
when they published the paper on a
simpler method for making conductive ink
Jordan bunker who had had no experience
with chemistry until then read this
paper and reproduced the experiment at
his makerspace using only off-the-shelf
substances and tools he used a toaster
oven and he even made his own vortex
mixer based on a tutorial by another
scientist / maker Jordan then published
his results online including all the
things he had tried it didn't work so
others could study and reproduce it so
Jordans main form of innovation was to
take an experiment created in a
well-equipped lab at the University and
recreated in a garage in Chicago
using only cheap materials and tools he
made himself and now that he published
his work others can pick up where he
left and divide even simpler processes
and improvements another example of like
to mention is a Hennepin or Wilson's kit
of no parts her project's goal is to
highlight Express
qualities of materials while focusing on
the creativity and skills of the builder
electronics kids are very powerful in
that they teach us how things work but
the constrains inherent in their design
influence the way we learn so Hannah's
approach on the other hand is to
formulate a series of techniques for
creating unusual objects that free is
from pre-designed constraints by
teaching us about the materials
themselves so amongst Hannah's many
impressive experiments this is one of my
favorite what we've seen here is just a
piece of paper with some copper tape on
it connected to an mp3 player in a
magnet
so based on the research by Marcel
Aquila from MIT Hanna created a series
of paper speakers out of a wide range of
materials from simple copper tape to
conductive fabric and ink just like
Jordan and so many other makers Hannah
published her recipes and allows anyone
to copy and reproduce them her paper
electronics is one of the most promising
branches of material science in that it
allows us to create cheaper and flexible
electronics so Hannah's artisanal work
in the fact that she shared her findings
opens the doors to a series of new
possibilities that are both
aesthetically appealing and innovative
so the interesting thing about makers is
that we create out of passion and
curiosity and we are not afraid to fail
we often tackle problems from
unconventional angles and in the process
end up discovering alternatives or even
better ways to do things so the more
people experiment with materials the
more researchers are willing to share
their research maeín manufacturers their
knowledge the better chances we have to
create technologies that truly serve us
all so I feel a bit as Ted Nelson must
have when in the early 1970s he wrote
you must understand computers now back
then computers were these large
mainframes only scientists cared about
and no one dreamed of even having one at
home so it's a little strange that I'm
standing here and saying you must
understand smart materials now just keep
in mind that acquiring pre-emptive
knowledge about emerging technologies is
the best way to ensure that we have a
saying the making of our future thank
you
[Applause]